hey what's up my name's samuel leeds
i've been in property now for over 12
years i've done over 450 property deals
and in this video i'm going to be
answering your questions around property
so if you've got niggly questions and
you need help you have challenges then
comment those challenges comment those
questions in the comment box and i'm
gonna do my very best to help you
specifically with those issues i'm gonna
be answering some questions from last q
a sunday last week and honestly there's
so many interesting questions there's a
guy who just bought a house from auction
and then regrets it because he bought it
blind and he said it's in a really
really bad street so i'm going to be
talking about that and tackling that
issue there's somebody who's thinking
about buying a campsite there's a 17
year old that's thinking about getting
into deal sourcing but he's not sure if
he should do deal sourcing or rent to
rent and a whole host of other questions
and problems someone wanted to get in
with co deal sources and wondering how
to convince kodi or sources to work with
him so if this sounds interesting then
stay tuned hit the like button but i
don't just want to be answering other
people's questions right now i want to
be answering your questions so comment
your questions below as we are going so
i'm going to start with this auction
situation so syed hussein says i bought
a property from london in auction i
didn't see the property before i bought
it big mistake the road the house is on
is really run down any advice how i can
just sell it on quickly and make a
profit i'm willing to sell it for cheap
260 000 pounds three-bedroom terrace in
raynham london
so
again as always the first thing i'll say
is when someone hits the rocks at least
they can be is a lighthouse for other
people so if you're watching this video
and you're thinking about getting into
property never buy a property blind from
auction that is not a suggested thing to
do also make sure that you read the
legal pack and you have a survey on the
property before you bid however that
doesn't help side right now because
syed's in this situation so
what i'd probably say say it is
if you've bought a property from auction
it sounds to me like you kind of just
bought it blind didn't know the area
super well and now you're like oh man i
just want to shift this property maybe
it needs a lot of work i don't know the
full details first thing i would do is i
would just speak to a local estate agent
and i would say to them look how much
will this property sell for on the open
market it may be that you do manage to
make a good profit the problem is it's
just a bit of a gamble you know you kind
of just took a punt in the dark it might
pay off i hope it does but the very
first thing i would do is i'd speak to a
loca a couple of local estate agents
tell them about the house let them look
round and they will be able to tell you
very quickly how much the house will
sell for in the open market and hey
hopefully you bought it cheap and you're
able to make a good profit but if not if
you end up breaking even at least it's a
lesson so uh if you need any help
further though sorry just drop me a
message on instagram i'm very happy to
look at the property and
hey if we can do business and make money
then amazing hope that helps marketing
mat
is owning a campsite a good investment
to cash flow
that i can then inject into property
i'm looking to buy some land in a prime
location and get one acre of land for
about 10 to 15 grand put in 30 to 40
pitches at 60 capacity you gross 12 000
pounds per month um so the first thing
is if you're buying land even if you
don't as a campsite you will still need
to get permission from the council to do
that so just bear that in mind you can't
just necessarily pitch camps um caravans
and stuff without permission so bear
that in mind it's not something that
i've personally done but i have had
quite a few students do it also my
parents i've just bought a piece of land
in the peak district with the exact sole
thing wanting to do what you're wanting
to do and it's definitely a good
business my best advice would be before
you invest in any business you just need
to understand the business
if you're investing in holiday let's you
need to understand holiday let's if
you're investing in hmos you need to
install htmls so i think it's a good
business model i definitely think it can
work also it kind of still is property
investing in a way because you're still
owning the land which is going to go up
in value and then you've got the trading
business which is the actual campsite so
do your market research
check the area check the demand i think
it's a great business but make sure that
you know and understand the business
before you invest in it i hope that
helps marketing mats all right ola
tokunbu says my name is ola oh that
would have been easier wouldn't it i'm
17 years old my target this year is to
make 5 000 pounds in property investing
all right so you're 17 years old 5 000
pounds per month or just 5 000 pounds if
it's 5 000 pounds per month it's doable
if it's just 5 000 pounds this year
it's too doable i mean most people's
problem
in this business is not that they have
their goals too high and miss most
people's problem is that they set their
goals too low and hit so i hope that's 5
000 pounds a month um i'm just wanting
to know what property strategy is best
for me as i live in south london deal
sourcing or
rent to rent
great question okay so i can't possibly
tell you olu what the best strategy is
for you you know why because i don't
know you i don't know your goals i don't
know what you're good at i don't know
what you love doing so
deal sourcing is really really i love
deal sourcing because number one it's
you can make very quick money um you're
learning how to find deals at the same
time as getting paid and the best deals
that you find you're going to keep them
for yourself so i love deal sourcing for
that reason however rent to rent is good
because you've got a recurring income
coming from it you're not having to make
a sale every time you want to get paid
so they've both got their advantages but
i would probably suggest doing both why
would you not do both package and sell a
couple of deals and then put that money
into some rental rents so i'd probably
do both and i hope to see you win big
time if you want to come down to one of
our training programs i'll leave a link
in the description we have got free
tickets right now limited spaces so olu
grab a ticket right now that'll be
amazing
all right next
abdur says
what's the best way to convince people
to co-deal source with you if you don't
have any rep so if you don't have a
reputation and you're wanting people to
code your source with you um
this is what i'd probably say abdur
you're saying how do i convince people
to code your source with me
but people that are wanting to code
source with you
you you're not going to be able to
convince them not just because you
haven't got a good rep but you need to
find somebody
that wants
someone to code your source with them so
what do i mean by that rather than
thinking about you rather than thinking
about how can i get money how can i
convince somebody
you need to be thinking
what are the deal sources out there that
have got more investors than they have
deals
see if there's a co deal if sorry if
there's a deal sourcer that's got a
thousand investors and they've got
investors chasing them for deals but
they ain't got the deals
they're not gonna need any convincing if
you just say to them hey i've got some
deals
would you be interested in passing them
to the investors and giving me a
kickback
they're not gonna need convincing
so you know i don't know if you've heard
the story about the the guy that wanted
to feed the pigeons there was two guys
that wanted to feed pigeons um you know
they just wanted to get fulfillment and
satisfaction from giving bread to
birds and one guy was chasing the
pigeons with the bread chasing the
pigeons and what would the pigeons do
the pigeons were running away
did the pigeons want the bread probably
but because he was chasing them with the
bread they were running away
and then the other guy just put his
hands out and put some bread on his
hands
and waited and the pigeons came and sat
went on his arms and ate the bread
so in the exact same way in business if
you're wanting to work with code deal
sources
then don't be chasing and trying to
convince
you need to understand marketing you
need to just let people know what it is
that you do
and stay still and don't chase anybody
let the word out but don't try and close
convince persuade just tell people what
you're doing and wait for them to come
find you ask questions say to them you
know oh um what what what kind of deals
are your investors looking for at the
moment okay great well look if i could
find some deals would you potentially be
interested in passing them onto your
investors okay awesome so you're just
asking questions and then if they're a
good fit
they'll they'll want to work with you i
hope that hope that um makes sense all
right last question amira mian
is there any way i can talk to you about
my situation um
yeah man of course you can you i'm
accessible bro drop me a message on
instagram uh or drop me a message on
facebook or drop me a message on
linkedin or drop me a message on tick
tock i i try and respond to every single
message on social media so i'll try my
best send me a message hit me up also if
you want to come and actually do some
training with me then i have got limited
spaces but i have got some free tickets
right now at the property investors
crash course check it out in the
description and i'll see you guys next
time peace
[Music]